so I told you yesterday about the latest
evidence that Donald Trump completely
and totally does not understand tariffs
sort of like at a fundamental very very
basic level but that that lack of
understanding doesn't stop him from
adding tariffs to China on Chinese goods
which of course as I explained yesterday
are actually paid by American companies
and by American consumers and we seem
now to have crossed over into actual
market panic and volatility as a result
of Donald Trump's completely misguided
and harebrained economic policy when it
comes to tariffs and China and yesterday
stocks were tumbling I don't do much
day-to-day stock market coverage on this
show we tend to take a big-picture view
but the reaction and the chaos around
Trump's tariffs is important and I have
to talk about it
we saw the Dow Jones Industrial Average
drop a little over 600 points are around
almost 3% we saw a massive drop in the
Nasdaq we saw a massive drop in the S&P
500 which is the broader of those three
major indices and this is all because of
this escalating trade war that Donald
Trump is waging against China without
understanding a thing about economics
without knowing anything about trade and
it's getting worse and worse and very
likely today stocks will rebound as is
often the case after these major major
drops and people will write to me and
they'll say David stocks dropped
yesterday but they recovered today well
more than likely you'll know by the time
you watch or listen to this which
because the trading day is still
happening today
the recovery today will not be as big as
the massive drop yesterday but the point
is the massive volatility day-to-day
that the president's misguided policies
are causing and I'm going to show you a
quote that tells us just how truly
ignorant Donald Trump is on this issue
of tariffs he said yesterday to White
House reporters we've never taken in ten
cents from China until I was elected
we're taking in billions of dollars in
tariffs I love the position that we are
in we've gone up a lot since our great
election
it means for a country to go up a lot is
is very dumb and childish and stupid but
the fundamental misunderstanding is that
China doesn't pay the tariffs the money
that Trump is talking about taking in is
coming from American companies and
American people who are paying the
tariffs this is a dangerous man who
doesn't understand fundamentally basic
things this is weaponized ignorant
stocks are crashing trump's ad chair
trump adds to tariffs to china china
adds tariffs Trump adds more tariffs and
then the whole circle sort of starts
again and again and meanwhile China
forges other relationships while our
companies and our people get screwed so
I'm gonna try another approach on this
today because there's lots of people who
are apparently as confused as Trump is
on this issue because I get emails from
people saying David you're against
tariff so you're a pro free-trade guy
free trades been a disaster for hundreds
of millions of people on this planet you
can't possibly be for free trade can you
David every single email I get that
attempts to make that economic analysis
forgets that countries don't exist in an
echo chamber the world didn't start in
2019 or 2018 if we were just starting
nation-states and setting up countries
today and economics and economies more
importantly didn't already have hundreds
of years of track records it would be a
philosophical debate over free trade vs.
protectionism and that philosophical
debate would have practical implications
that's not the reality right now we are
mostly engaged in a battle over
principles of free trade versus
protectionism that are only relevant in
the theoretical and sort of
philosophical world where countries
haven't existed for hundreds of years in
the real world we have 200 years almost
200 years of industrialization and
specialization so the way that Trump
claims the tariffs will work will simply
not work and this stuff can be tough to
explain clearly but if you don't get
this you can't possibly evaluate these
tariffs the idea of putting tariffs on
Chinese stuff to put it really simply is
if we make Chinese stuff more expensive
for American companies American
companies will choose to buy American
stuff to make their products instead so
in a sense you put tariffs on Chinese
stuff and it makes American business
more attractive for internal production
of different products but the problem is
that our economy and those of many
countries are specialized and
specialization is a concept where
countries decide we can't make
everything we can't make every product
we're gonna specialize in certain
industries or in certain materials or
goods or job types and we've been
specializing for a really long time and
in specialization it often makes sense
to trade with other countries even when
you have an absolute advantage in all
goods or in multiple goods relative to
other countries here's a look just a
super simple example from economics one
on one you got to understand this stuff
imagine a simple world where you have
two countries and two products okay it's
the US and China and the two things that
the US and China can choose to produce
are sweet potatoes and cars okay really
simple the United States might be better
might be more efficient at making sweet
potatoes than China but growing sweet
potatoes we would say and at making cars
than China even if the US has what's
called an absolute advantage in both
sweet potato and car production it can
still make sense to specialize and only
make one of those and to get the other
one from China as part of a trade policy
because of something called comparative
advantage even if we are in the absolute
sense better at making sweet potatoes
and cars than China the ratio by which
we are better at making one over the
other
would be different than that same ratio
in China in other words imagine a
situation where in the absolute we can
make more cars per day than China and we
can make more sweet potatoes per day
than China we might be significantly
better at making cars than sweet
potatoes whereas China might only be
slightly better at making cars than
sweet potato
and in that case it would make sense for
us to specialize make cars and get our
sweet potatoes from China we have 200
years of this there are switching costs
there's competitive advantage there's
economies of scale
anyone who's saying are you for free
trade or not because free trade has been
bad or protectionism is good or bad
you're imagining this as a theoretical
and philosophical issue that doesn't
relate to the practicalities and in the
meantime Trump's ignorance is growing
the trade war this is bad for the
economy we knew it would be Trump has no
off-ramp from these escalating tariffs
and we're in very serious trouble as the
stock market and even Trump's own
financial adviser Larry Kudlow are
telling us I am thrilled to tell you
that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink asam / Pakman blink astiz
a really unique service for your phone
tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka Steaks the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blink Asst our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink is calm slash Pakman that's
B Li NK is t-dot-com forward slash
PA que ma n